hey guys Matt here I'm redoing episode
two of cmake if you want to see the
original one I'll link it down below I'm
going to try to make a much shorter more
concise more information packed oh a
couple people mentioned that this could
be better I agree I'll give it a try I'm
going to try to show you as much as I
can here in episode two we're gonna
reiterate the point of executables and
how to do executables mainly on Linux
and we're going to start talking about
libraries and how to add just static
libraries make your own so what I've got
here is a Linux console this is Ubuntu
let me just show you a nice X cubital a
nice clean way of doing C plus plus uh
starter point template starter point on
Linux specifically I mean it's similar
on other os's but you're going to have
to make some adjustments as expected let
me see where I'm at here I'm going to
print working directory I'm in my source
so I made a little demo project in here
called trim and inside of it all it has
is a CPP folder so we'll go there
and I've got a cmake and a main and
another folder called build if we can
remove this command here to remove a
folder be careful with this command this
is dangerous oh all right so Bim main.cp
let's have a look at the code real quick
that's NRC plus class and
I'll just highlight it with my mouse
here as we go so all this does is it's a
main that takes in those arguments so
you passing arguments when you run it
program is called trim so all it does is
it just erases white space and new lines
and tabs and stuff I saw this code on I
was watching one of Javid X nines recent
videos great YouTube channel for C plus
plus stuff I was watching this Channel
and he had these functions I was like oh
let me test this out real quick here's
the interesting thing about these little
programs especially on Linux they're
very easy to make useful so normally you
build your program right and then then
what you just use it from its build
directory no there's a little more to it
so let's go ahead and build it so
generally the standard thing you want to
do when building is you want to be in
your Source directory of course or in
your project directory and you make a
folder called build and name it slightly
different if we want but it's kind of
standard to name it build or out and
we'll go into that field and this is
where we're going to run our cmake
Command we're going to run cmaid on the
preview directory in the build directory
is where we're already at so we don't
specify anything but of course shortcut
for Source Dash capital s
double dots so just go back directory
the sources in the previous directory
which makes sense if we just made a
build folder and went into uh the wordy
in the build folder so we don't need to
specify that because it's going to
default to the folder very simple very
straightforward cmake build and there it
goes it's all succeeded now if we do an
LS and list the files in this folder
in this build folder we get a make file
and we can take a look at the make file
if we want with I'm going to use cat
dash n and let's have a look Dash in
just shows all the line numbers right
here in your console and you can see
this make file very first line see make
generated file do not edit so make sure
make files I had the luck I guess luck
of being taught make files first most
people do not because make files are a
little more complicated but here's our
all they are it's the comment Line This
is a target I believe these are
dependencies and down below dependencies
tabbed over would be commands these dot
phonies are special configs basically
for targets there's not a whole lot else
to it I mean there is a lot more but I
don't want to get too deep too quickly
like you can Define things and you can
call them later with uh
dollar sign kind of like CMA with cmake
got some of their syntax from make files
you don't even need to know the smake
file stuff because cmake is front of
that but you know if you want to
completely skip or just not go the layer
above make you can not use cmake you
know there's also other ones like
pre-make I don't know there's a couple
others but you know some people complain
that there's layers of stuff I
yeah that's just the way it goes I don't
know what you expect there's always
going to be layers of stuff okay so if
we want to run that of course we need to
build it first running cmake does not
build your software it just configures
or make file in your make file all
makefile does as well makes not even
necessarily C plus plus related make
is actually just terminal related it
just runs commands in your terminal but
it is a little C plus plus related
because I think they have some shortcuts
built in C plus plus related things but
make just run stuff in your terminal so
it's just going to run all your build
commands if you run make and make when
you type make it looks for a make file
in that director it can be a capital or
an uncapital M doesn't matter with make
files when you type make it looks for
that make file and it runs a command it
runs a Target so you have different
targets when you leave it blank it runs
the very first one the top one which I
think was the default but you can go
well I think they have help to find as a
Target and it help just does some
console out stuff and there you go valid
targets for the smake file they've got
all clean depend list install components
rebuild let's take a look at our cmake
file backer directory and let's just
take a look at it with cats how many
lines do you think this cmake file is
going to have well it's only got four
it's four lines and you saw how big that
make file was right so you could type
these four lines and be done
or you could type up that entire make
file so that's kind of the work that
cmake does for you as an example and you
know we just looked at the make files so
you know how large it was and how
complicated looking it was this is
simple line one
a version of cmake required I didn't
need that makes sense declare your
project name with project but I just
called this one Capital true
add an executable give your executable
name tell it what source it needs
obviously skipping a lot of special
flags and stuff here but if you're not
super concerned with that you just need
something to run because you're actually
working on something else
I'll talk more about that shortly okay
this one is new and actually we haven't
even got to it in the series yet but
this is a really great thing to add if
you're using Linux because it just makes
your life easy all right so this install
it wants a Target
well you got to specify that it's
installing targets because there could
be multiple uh trim and that's got to be
in one of the executable names this
could also be a library we haven't got
to that yet so it's going to install an
executable where's it still install it
well it needs a destination and we're
going to call this one bit why Ben
because it's a binary let's put it in
the bin folder that's pretty standard
for Linux now Linux is going to install
if I'm not mistaken here based on your
user preference so let's do this let's
go back into our build directory
make sure our C makes up to date let's
go C mate Source in the previous
directory and then let's just run make
and build our Target so what does this
program do well all it does is take in
any jump you pass in and lines
and it removes all the spaces and spits
out
like so that's all the program does but
if you want to run it anytime you run it
you've got a path it through this build
directory and get to the executable
right so that can be kind of annoying
you can make shortcuts and do a little
special configs to fix that if you want
but that's really complicated all you
really have to do is put this install
line and you're good because then you
can just go well make sure we're on our
build folder here and we are
you can just go make
install
and it will build it have an error
because permission denied this is trying
to write to where your executables are
stored on your Linux machine which by
default users don't have right access to
they only have read access to this so
you needs you need super user to make
install this is going to prompt for an
admin credentials which might be you if
you've made yourself that sort of person
or root access I guess would be a better
way to say it and you just type in your
password here in that case it gives you
access to write installs the project
there's no config for this one we
haven't got to that and it says it
installed it in user local bin which is
what I was going to go try to find
manually school that it just says it
here because that saves me time so
that's where it's going to install user
local bin on Direct all right so now I
can go anywhere on my computer I just
hit change directory with no arguments
which is going to take me to my home
directory you can see I'm at home and
now you would think I can't run trim
easily run trim now I would have to go
um
into what source I need to go the whole
directory path there we go
there like that would run it sure but do
I want to have to type that the whole
time no well you don't have to anymore
because now it's installed it's just
there so you can just no matter where
you're at you can just feed it commands
and you can do this with Linux programs
or with a C plus plus and Linux all you
want you can make little projects that
just do little things and take in little
arguments install them and they're ready
at the drop of a dime you just open your
terminal and type things up it's also
great for data science you can just pipe
in your your data file for example if
you have something that processes a
bunch of data you could go whatever your
file is not or whatever your program is
not necessarily trim it's just the one I
have in my example is um and then you
pass in whatever argument we want maybe
you have like the data dot CSV and your
program knows how to handle this data
set it just wants the file you would
design it in the same fashion you just
obviously be a lot more complicated than
this basic trim but the cmake would
essentially be about the same now you
can do it like this now also this builds
in debug by default and if you want it
in release which is going to be a little
more faster and a little more optimized
getting into debug versus release gets
into some cmake build type stuff um
I don't know if it's worth quite getting
into yet it might just make it a bit
more confusing so I think we'll wait a
little bit but uh I just want to say
that later in the series I do already
have an episode on installing up and it
goes a little deeper than this and it
gets a little more complicated so I
think this is a cleaner example of how
to do the install and it's going to get
you going a little faster if you're just
getting started and just kind of want to
like make a little useful program yeah
just be careful of course C plus plus is
a powerful language that can rearrange
memory if you let it so
um that's another contentious thing it's
like how simple do I want to make this
because
you know you don't necessarily want
people that don't know what they're
doing poking around creating software
with ADD with admin rights because they
could mess up systems so you know in a
way there's got to be a steep learning
curve because you don't want to be you
know messing with critical processes
when you don't know what you're doing
you're gonna break something so just
just be aware of that I guess and be
careful is what I'm saying if you're new
and you know just double check that your
program does what it actually is
supposed to do that's that's going down
a rabbit hole all right so we've kind of
heavily reiterated how to and gone over
an example of just a very very basic
program getting it up and running
getting it installed and kind of making
C plus plus useful with cmake and saving
you a lot of time of all the overhead of
build systems by just typing those four
lines so those four lines are the big
takeaway but obviously we want to talk
about libraries really quick
the repo for this particular series is
kind of way ahead so I'm just gonna do a
quick little clean example right here
and I'll just talk through everything
I'm doing let's make a static library in
the most simple way with using cmake as
the the build system so the first thing
you need to know here before you even
touch cmake is with C plus how do you
make a library because you know you you
do all the code and the build system is
what says try to make this a library
so we got to do the code first and then
we can configure the build system to
tell it to try to make it a library and
it's really that simple
so let's make a new project here
I'm going to use maker and just make a
fresh directory and I'm going to call it
some live some live demo in this piece
of software I'm going to make another
directory called CPP or C plus plus and
we're going to go into that directory
we're liking to do this lately in my new
projects
rather than Source or code just to name
it the language expected
so in the CPP file let's make our actual
code I think we can just open up a new
file let's open up a main.cb well put on
the brakes for a second we're making a
library here we don't actually need a
main for a library there's no entry
point that runs from top to bottom in a
library a libraries functions that you
call from your own main that you make
somewhere else so we don't need a main
unless it's some sort of tester so
hopefully that makes sense but let's do
an example so let's make
mule Adder Library same deal let's make
a dot h it's a header file so we
definitely need pragma once here we need
to define the functions that we want
let's go ahead and make a namespace here
just for the sake of good C plus plus
and I'm just going to call this uh early
math
just to keep it in my own little
personal namespace of my math functions
that way I don't interfere with other
people's accidentally
because to go off on another thing that
you'll run into at some point so I'm
saving you time in the future probably
at some point you will try to call a
function and you'll get this weird error
that says it's ambiguous and that there
are multiple versions of it your code
and compiler doesn't know what you're
talking about and you're going to spend
about three to four hours searching on
Google asking everyone you know what the
heck's going on and how do you fix this
and the answer is well you've got the
function defined in multiple libraries
so you've included headers that have
overlapping function names or
overlapping variable names maybe even
and the way that you can make sure that
that doesn't happen is you put them in
different name spaces or you can make
them really unique names but some names
just tend to get reused a lot so if you
put it in a namespace then you're pretty
well guaranteed not to be overlapping
with someone else's code names or
function names in this way we can make
our function names very simple so let's
make an Adder that just uh
takes in any type and adds them together
now that's not taking any type I don't
want people adding characters and stuff
that'll get weird let's just do uh
integers and floats so we're going to
return an integer and we're just going
to call add and we'll just take two
numbers to start integer a and integer
now I'm kind of skipping some standards
here so I'm just making the code a
little bit more simple we're gonna make
a float version too yeah you could
attempt with this bonus points if you
template it make it all fancy and handle
a lot of stuff this is all we need for
our header right now this is all we're
gonna do you can extrapolate and add as
many functions as you want in your own
Library you can also do classes that
constantiate and stuff we're kind of
skipping classes here and just going
straight to making functions so okay now
that we're done here let's just write
this file out and quit with this command
here in vim and now we should have that
file there we should be able to take a
look at it and see what it looks like
and we just need definitions for those
so let's make an Associated C plus file
and this one we're going to go into
insert mode include the adder.h double
quotes since it's in the same directory
and just declare the namespaces on the
definitions the first one we have was
the integer version and it's in add
and it just wants the two variables all
of them A and B and we're just going to
return a plus b nothing fancy here and
Float will be very similar okay and we
can write that out and quit Okay so
that's actually all we need we've got a
couple function definitions now we just
want to build this into a library so how
do we command cmake to do that
no problem wait let's make a cement file
and it's spelled just like this on the
top level and of course we need c make
minimum required version
I usually say 2.8 you're supposed to do
a version that at least supports
everything you're doing in your cmake
file because there's there's some stuff
about it that you can't do to till later
versions and stuff like that but you'll
learn that later
so not a huge deal now we just need
to know what's going on here we need a
project of course so let's put project
and I'm just going to call it from early
math I suppose and we need usually you
do an ad executable here we don't have
an executable in this case we have just
function definitions so we're going to
do instead of yeah executable just add
Library
it's not a library and it's very similar
to the executable syntax from here it
just wants a name I'm just going to call
it currently math same as project name
doesn't necessarily have the same name
as the project name but this is how the
library is going to show up it's going
to have this name so merely math is fine
that keeps it kind of streamlined and
then it just needs to know what source
you're working with here and well we're
working with only two files one of them
is a header one C plus plus file and we
really actually in this case only need
to compile the C plus file because it it
just has everything that we need and
we'll see if we get any errors that file
which is called adder.cp and then we can
write and quit now let's go ahead and
make build folder and work with the
cmake connector bill
change directly into build now let's run
cmake with the source being on the
previous level we're already in the
build directory so nothing else needed
if we're leaving it all default there it
goes
cmake completed without errors so our
cmake syntax is good and the files exist
but now let's see if the make file runs
so we type make and it builds a Target
and you can see it says what it did here
building an object adder.o linking
static Library live merlimat so you see
it takes the name of your that you put
early math it puts live in front of it
that's standard for
Linux it's live in front of it and then
a DOT a DOT A's are static libraries
if you see a live with a DOT so it's a
shared object
also Dia those are dlls and windows
Dynamic link libraries they're shared
odd objects in Linux Mac
so dot so is that and you see we've
built it so what do we do from here
there's nothing to run it just has
functions in it well as we mentioned
before you need your own main so for
example let's go let's just go back a
directory another directory it was
terminal and
I've messed up my file directories a bit
I'm meant to be in Source when I was
creating some of those so I'm actually
going to correct that up and do it and
this is the way to move files around and
Linux if you want to learn it I'll show
that real quick since I'm doing it if
not we can tap the skip forward a bit
go into Source what's in my source I
have the timer demo and trip I want the
sub live demo to also be it Source but I
think that CBP there was supposed to be
in the sum live demo as well yeah it was
okay so we're going to go move
a CPP folder in the sub live demo folder
and it just runs
so you know this is a command that was
probably built with C plus plus the way
we did it took in some arguments and it
did some stuff you see took in two
arguments and did some stuff
you can make your own programs that do
that too so now when we do the ls our
cpp's gone because we moved it so much
okay cool
so now what we want to do is move some
live demo into source and there we go
we've cleaned it up properly it's now on
our source where it was intended to be
to begin with didn't have to drag files
around and go through folders all with
command line you can do this all the
command line you probably already know
that but kind of Mr Rogers some code
here okay all right so let's go back
into some some live demo back into that
C plus plus folder in there where we've
built all our stuff
and let's go just take a look at the
library here but obviously it's uh it's
right here but if anyone uses this
Library they also need the headers the
headers basically say uh to your code
it's a declaration of things to expect
in this Library here are the definitions
so sound familiar you know when you
first learn C plus plus and they have
you put the
declarations at the top that's uh these
header Parts basically and when they
have you make
the definition somewhere else well
that's all built in here this is the
definition so that's all libraries are
they're definitions of functions but you
still need to know about the functions
being declared and that's where that dot
h comes in so if we want to make another
project useless stuff well we just make
another project and we just bring in
this Library so check this out let's go
back with the rest go back with them
yeah let's just make
another project here real quick we're
just call I'm going to call this test
cell let's stick with our standards and
make a be bolder again and let's just
make a main
and in here we want to use that Adder we
can we just need to include the header
file and we need to link the library the
link in the library will come later see
make so we don't need to necessarily do
that here but we want to know what
functions we can call so that's why we
absolutely need the header now where is
the header well from a directory
standpoint we know where it is on this
computer so usually people make some
folder called like external or lives or
something and they drag all the headers
into it sometimes or if you have project
config that sorts it out for you and you
don't want to that's fine because if
you're using most modern IDs and stuff
they know where to look for a lot of
your libraries just by their configs so
I'm kind of going very raw with it here
and uh you know a lot of Ides and
package managers abstract this so you
never need to know it so just want to
make that clear that if you never see
this that's probably why but if we want
to include that Library we'd either have
to put it in to this folder locally put
the header into here locally or just
path to it we know it's like what back
let's think about this back to
directories first one goes into this
project second back goes into source and
then we want to go into some live demo
and the C plus plus there and then the
adder.h that's that should be a path
that works but uh
we'll talk more about this later and how
to simplify this because clearly you
don't want to do this with all your
headers so uh when we get to the cmake
I'll address that and simplify it
because you can tell it you can tell
cmake where your library headers are or
where you include directories are let's
make it a main we're not going to take
in any arguments and we just want to
Simply use the library so let's see if
we can call it if a function name was
add something from early math this
should allow us to call it let's return
the value so we should just see it in
the command line obviously that should
add up five we know that our add
function does that we can go look it in
the header
uh the definition is not there but
generally there's if people do libraries
in this way
then they uh they usually have a comment
telling you exactly what the function
does if you can't see the definition by
the header but that should be all we
need here to use our library so let's
just make sure it gets linked this is
where we need cmake again so let's just
make a cmake file go in insert mode and
do the standard or in a different
project here just call it test sum and
this time we are making an execute we
used to know about our main of course
and we need to link the link in the
library super important so how do we do
that well arcit Library
and now it needs to know what Target
it's our Target that we're just declared
up there with that executable sorry this
is libraries and now we just need to
feed it the libraries now when you feed
it libraries it only expects the name
doesn't expect the live in the front
it'll sort that out automatically it
doesn't expect a DOT a at the end it'll
sort that out automatically it just
wants the library name as you exported
it in your other cb8 so that way you
don't have to worry about the live at
the front and the a at the end just to
simplify it
and this should this should work should
I know it will I know it won't work but
in theory you've got the executable you
know like the library why wouldn't it
work
well it doesn't know where this library
is that's why now doing an install with
this Library would solve that they would
know where it is because Linux would put
it in the path where it knows where to
find c plus libraries however we haven't
done that so if we want to use it in
this custom special way we have to tell
it and the way we do that is we go
Target Library directories I'm going to
look that up that's certainly wrong but
it's close Target link directories same
Target
and then it just wants to know okay what
directory are we finding these libraries
that you're going to link later where
are they at so we need the entire path
uh to that library and we know that it's
in our source folder so we could go and
use little shortcuts here we can go
cmake
silver stir and then see that would be
the top level of this project or the CPP
at least go back a directory and that
would be the project folder there go
back another directory that would be
into our source folder on Linux here and
then from there we know that it's in our
sum live demo folder and then from there
CP and then if you want to build and
that's where it should be it should be
right there so let's add that directory
and say we're going to find libraries
there okay now Target link directories
was not added to cmake until 3.13
so if you're using this you need to make
sure you change your minimum required to
3.13 and that's where this version is
comes in you just want to make sure
someone's running a version
that supports what you're doing now this
should in theory work we may want quotes
around that entire link directory not
sure but we definitely need one more
thing here actually we need to know if
it's interface public or private in this
case
it is going to be
insert mode here it's going to be
private private just means that let me
make sure I explained this right okay
well I'm just going to read it off the
page because I feel like I'm going to
butcher it if I try to custom say it
interface public private keywords are
required to specify the scope of the
items that follow them so it's going to
scope these items it says public
interface will populate the interface
link directories Target
and so I'm guessing the private ones
just don't I think for most cases when
you're making your own custom executable
you're going to want them private
because you don't necessarily need to
expose the libraries you're using
so private's going to be fine in our
case kind of makes it a little more
black box to the end user I guess
all right so we filled out our cmake
we've filled our main we think we got it
linking correctly let's see if it builds
so we're going to make our build
directory here go into that build
directory Runner C make Command Source
in the previous directory seems to be
fine running that let's see if the make
file runs makes with no errors whatever
the case I'm Mighty proud well if that
linked correctly then
and it built correctly it should just
run and it should spit out at five
because it's going to return five we did
an add of two and three right in the
code if it all works and uses the
library you should get a five I guess we
need to either console it out or somehow
hold the return value so I guess we
could go this work
no that's just going to look at the
binary
hold on I need how are we going to do we
piping it right okay we've got to go
Echo I don't know the values just
returned to the operating system so I
guess we could just we could just do a
console out I know avoid that meal lever
so let's include i o stream it just
thought
let's make it super clear in the code
here put a new line character at the end
let's still return the value actually
well this this return value is something
different this return value returns to
operating system basically as a true or
false in a lot of cases so let's just
return 0 for X's success so we can even
use this keyword or macro
and we should be able to write that out
and quit and now let's go do the same
thing again we can just run make we
don't need to run the cmake command
again the make file stays the same since
the files are still the same if you're
adding files and stuff then you need to
regenerate but
if you just change the contents of one
file you typically don't need to
regenerate your results May Vary
all right so make is fine a bill we can
run it again and we should get some
output yeah so it pulled this 5 here
from that Library which means we got
everything correct very nice so
now I was saying that what if you don't
have an exact path to your library maybe
you're getting it off the internet or
something so
you might want to link link it and use
the header or you probably want to build
it and then link and use the header
typically don't want to well make this
for what you will on Linux at least you
typically want to build your own stuff
but on Windows you'll see like oh here's
a pre-built x64 version of the live and
here's the headers so
you don't get to see the source the
definitions of everything's hidden in
that Library
and then they just provide you with the
Declarations the headers to go with it
so a lot of libraries are closed source
and that's how they do it but open
source ones you can typically pull down
build your own link on your own
and uh hopefully you're starting to
understand that by watching the series
because that's kind of the big takeaway
of uh at least in part of this series
But ultimately we've got this awkward
dot dot
specifications for where it is
so basically what we're going to do here
well you could copy it in to your
project and just kind of make it local
to your project that way you have to
don't have to do all that that's what
most people do but I want to just want
to show you another option that kind of
expands on the workflow we've been
working with this is somewhat of
standard Linux workflow so let's get out
of this and let's actually go back to
our library so go back to our sourcer go
back to some live demo and let's just
work up this C make a little bit now
this is where the fun begins
now if we just go install targets
I don't even know our Target already and
we need a destination if this one goes
in live so this does get into a bit of a
wrapped hole I'm just going to pull this
over and talk for a second about this
we're only looking at normal libraries
all right you see there's object
interface imported Alias they have their
uses I don't personally use these ones
as much so I'm not familiar enough to
talk about them a ton but I think
they're other specific cases and most of
the time I believe you're just going to
be using uh so that's what we're going
over if you want to know more check the
documentation and make sure the version
you're using supports what you're
working with but ultimately here what we
need to know about ad Library as well we
want a name we already took care of that
we need to put static or shared and
there's other stuff here too but we're
pretty pretty much only going to do
static in this example here I've never
missed modules so I don't even know how
to explain it without doing some
research and then ultimately we're going
to need the source and optionally this
exclude from all we're also not going to
get into generator Expressions just yet
uh I will at some point though they're
very useful at times okay modules are
linked at runtime that's something I
would like to explore so now I've never
really gone into that too much
I think we'll stick with static I was
just thinking of maybe showing shared
but I think we've covered enough already
we're gonna stick with static if no type
is given explicitly the type is static
or shared based on whether the current
value of the variable build shared lives
is on so you can set this build shared
lives to true or false when you
configure cmake the make sure we get it
installed it's called important let's
let's install this thing okay install
targets we're going to go with
destination live here rather than
and we also need to put the headers in
here as well
okay so we can kind of pack this all
into one command but we need to make
sure the library knows what headers it
uses so the way we're going to do that
is with set Target properties
and just referencing here so we put in
our Target name for what Target we're
saying the properties of and then the
properties keyword here
and then public header
keyword and then your dot h files now
with that
we can go on this install we can go
Library destination
well we want that to go into live your
path might be different but with Linux
it's just live then we also want on this
install the public
header
destination we got Library destination
at public header destination for this
target
and you want this to be your include
path I believe it in Linux it's just
going to be include and you might do a
subfolder of your project name want
maybe we'll do this is all one command
I've just broke it into multiple lines
that one meets an underscore all right
let's give this a try let's write this
out let's go into our build directory
and try it again we'll go see main
source the previous directory give it a
try get some confused stuff doesn't
match the cache rerun with a different
Source or directory well we can just uh
again just delete everything in our
build directory that should take care of
it and uh from here we should be able to
run clean
and there we go now we should be able to
go make install let's see what happens
we've got an error of permission denied
that is expected just need to super user
this to go make install once a password
in there we see that it did the install
local live there it's in there lope will
include it's in there go back to our
other program
that uses the library now and now we can
adjust accordingly because we could in
theory you know these local files for
working on it
those aren't necessarily going to be
there or maybe someone will clone this
test some somewhere else so we can't
rely on this structure to be like that
so since we did the install we don't
need to rely on that structure anymore
so let's edit our CMA
and now we can get rid of all this link
directory because it already has a link
directory just Linux is going to have
that he knows about that path already so
we could just link it and also knows
about the headers already so we don't
need to do a special header directory
either let's go back into our build
directory and just regenerate this thing
so we are going to do another plane here
of this directory and then we are going
to rerun our cmake now we can go make
and just make sure it builds it builds
if it builds successfully that's good it
means it found the library and it also
found the headers so our edits and our
expectations of it knowing where they
were are correct thanks to the OS
handling some stuff for us and now we
should be able to at last run it
and we get our result looks fine there
so it seems to be working and that's
pretty much it I think we're done with
this episode we've went over a lot we've
went over how to make an executable how
to install the executable on your
computer and just run it from your
command line at any time how to make a
library how to install the library now
if we made a C plus plus program
anywhere on this environment we could
just use this Library we created without
having to specify any special include
directories without having to specify
any special link directories because
they're where they expect well take it
easy guys keep coding reach out to me if
you need to I'll be around best ways
through Discord and through the the
patreon or through the business email if
you've got business stuff for code Tech
tutorials alright peace out
foreign
[Music]